[Musique]
merci Étienne blonde de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure cette
sénateur du Rhône monde des républiques
on va évidemment parler de votre
territoire et de la proposition de loi
que vous comptez déposer mais d'abord on
l'a vu l'actualité c'est encore toujours
l'inflation et cette mesure annoncée ce
weekend par Elisabeth borde d'autoriser
la vente à perte sur les carburants
pendant une durée limitée est-ce que
vous voterez cette mesure je veux très
mais je la voudrais à contrecœur et quel
est le problème sur les carburants
le problème ce sont pas les marges qui
sont faites par les distributeurs ou par
les entreprises pétrolières le problème
c'est les taxes et on a un gouvernement
et c'est pas le seul sujet qui passe son
temps à faire les poches des
contribuables des particuliers des
familles qui fait les poches des
entreprises mais qui ne se posent pas la
seule question qui vaille plus de 60% du
prix d'un litre d'essence ou d'un litre
de gasoil c'est de la taxe fiscale ou
para fiscale c'est de la TVA c'est de la
taxe intérieure sur les produits
pétroliers etc c'est ça le font du
problème alors c'est un peu facile pour
un gouvernement déjà les Français fêtent
des efforts les entreprises fait des lui
que fait-il donc il aurait dû baisser
les taxes plutôt que demander aux
entreprises
bien sûr mais pour baisser les taxes il
y a un préalable c'est que le
gouvernement doit aujourd'hui revoir les
politiques publiques la France
fonctionne mal l'administration
fonctionne mal elle se bureaucratise et
cette bureaucratie nous coûte
terriblement cher ce travail-là le
gouvernement ne le fait pas c'est ça le
font du problème alors aller chercher
chez les particuliers aller chercher de
notre dans les entreprises c'est un peu
trop facile mais du coup vous la voterez
ou pas la mesure moi je la voterai
c'était évident parce que les Français
n'en peuvent plus donc si on peut
baisser un tant soit peu le prix oui
mais dans le principe et si on raisonne
globalement le gouvernement fait pas le
job
direct est-ce que vous êtes inquiet des
conséquences de cette mesure sur les
petites stations services notamment dans
le rural alors merci hier s'est engagé à
décompensation est-ce que c'est
suffisant pour vous est-ce qu'on se rend
compte la situation ubuesque dans
laquelle on est enfin est-ce qu'on s'en
rend compte on va autoriser les ventes à
perte puis en même temps on va financer
les stations de distribution mais c'est
une un demi totalement administrés sont
des décisions publiques qui adminisent
dans le détail la vie des Français la
vie des entreprises allons voir ce qui
se passe chez nos voisins chez nos
partenaires la France est un des
derniers pays d'Europe a imaginé que le
bonheur il se fait avec la dépense
publique
on a 54 % de dépenses publiques 45 % de
prélèvement obligatoire et ça ne marche
pas
parmi les arguments invoqués par le
gouvernement pour ne pas justement
baisser les taxes et la question de
l'écologie le gouvernement dit on va pas
continuer à subventionner des énergies
fossiles est-ce que vous qui avez
travaillé notamment sur la question de
l'hydrogène c'est ce type d'énergie
qu'il faut financer il faut arrêter de
financer les énergies fossiles sur on
sait aujourd'hui que les énergies
fossiles elles émettent du carbone et
que le carbone pose un problème à la
planète il faut donc avoir une politique
vigoureuse transformée ces énergies
fossiles en d'autres énergies et en
l'état actuel des données scientifiques
il n'y a pas d'autres solutions que de
développer la filière nucléaire
alors la filière nucléaire une époque
elle inquiétait parce que il fallait
beaucoup d'eau pour refroidir les
centrales et puis il y avait le problème
des déchets mais aujourd'hui avec la
filière à neutrons rapide on a apporté
une réponse à ces deux soucis on produit
beaucoup moins de déchets et surtout on
brûle les déchets à ceux qui sont
stockés on peut les utiliser pour
produire de l'énergie ça permet aussi à
la France de se souvenir de ce qu'a fait
madame Voynet lorsque Madame Voynet a
détruit raymanville lorsqu'elle a fait
percer les cuves de kremel ville pour
éviter qu'un jour créma de ville ne
reprennent ses activités c'était une
technologie d'avenir sur la filière à
notre rapide qui permettait d'apporter
une réponse si aujourd'hui nous avions
crémalville avec toutes les conséquences
sur le plan scientifique des recherches
que l'on effectue à kremelville la
question de l'énergie en tout cas de
l'électricité serait pas un problème
pour la France l'autre sujet d'actualité
c'est la question de l'immigration après
la venue de milliers de migrants sur
l'île italienne de Lampedusa Gérald
Darmanin s'est rendu hier soir en Italie
à Rome rencontrer son homologue se pose
la question de la venue de ces migrants
en France notamment via la frontière
franco-italienne pour en parler on va
aller justement dans les Alpes-Maritimes
à Nice retrouver Denis carro bonjour
Denis merci beaucoup d'être avec nous on
est ravis de vous retrouver cette saison
Denis Denis directeur des rédactions du
groupe Nice Matin quelle est la
situation actuellement à la frontière
italienne de nuit
la situation elle est bien résumé dans
le titre de Nice-Matin faire face à
l'urgence c'est le mot d'ordre à la
frontière italienne ou les migrants
tentants permanence de rentrer en France
30 000 d'entre eux ont été interpellés
depuis le début de l'année par les
policiers les gendarmes et les douaniers
présents sur place c'est les chiffres
qui ont été donnés hier par la
préfecture des Alpes-Maritimes et pour
la seule semaine du 8 au 14 septembre
c'est 15000 personnes qui ont été
arrêtées à la à la frontière alors hier
soir le préfet des Alpes-Maritimes a dû
démentir une information qui tournait
qui a tourné une partie de la journée
l'installation d'un camp de migrants à
la frontière
il l'a dit hier soir pas question pour
l'état de voir grandir un Calais ou un
Sangatte sur sur la Côte d'Azur qui est
depuis des mois et des années le passage
obligé pour pour les gens qui tentent
leur France leur chance en Europe alors
si la préfecture réfute le terme de Caen
une solution est quand même à l'étude
pour accueillir une centaine de migrants
le préfet des Alpes-Maritimes explique
que ça sera en quelque sorte une
extension de la police aux frontières
mais on voit bien
au-delà des termes choisis par par
l'État qu'il y a la nécessité de mettre
en place une une structure pour gérer
l'urgence et faire face à cette afflux
qui ne fait que qui ne fait que
qu'augmenter alors en attendant les
associations s'organisent on est allé à
leur rencontre du côté italien entre
Vintimille et la frontière avec avec la
France elle s'organise pour distribuer
de la de la nourriture et elle nous
confirme que depuis quelques jours et on
voit là l'effet de Lampedusa qui ne va
que faire que s'accentuer les migrants
sont de plus en plus nombreux à ce à se
présenter alors j'en viens à ma question
monsieur le sénateur on voit bien que
nous sommes au cœur d'une crise qui va
s'installer et qui va qui va durer
est-ce que l'attitude la réaction du
gouvernement français est à la hauteur
de cette situation
je ne crois pas et cette question
migratoire elle pose d'abord un problème
d'humanité notre civilisation elle s'est
construite sans doute sous l'influence
d'une civilisation chrétienne de cette
phrase de Saint-Paul tu accueilleras à
l'étranger et tout notre droit il s'est
construit sur ce principe là c'est
l'accueil les gens qui sont persécutés
dans le monde c'est accueille des gens
qui souffrent c'est l'honneur de la
France et puis d'un autre côté nous
avons aujourd'hui une véritable
déferlante et en raison de ces
déferlantes nous sommes amenés à nous
poser la question de savoir qui nous
accueillons et qui nous accueillons pas
nous ne pourrons pas comme des
émisselles requin accueillir toute la
misère du monde et c'est là où il y a
une faiblesse du droit français
d'abord il y a une faiblesse une
faiblesse du droit français mais surtout
une faiblesse du droit européen le droit
français il est placé sous l'autorité du
droit européen en fait nous appliquons
des directives mais une jurisprudence
européenne nous ne sommes plus libres et
c'est la première question que doit se
poser le gouvernement français j'ai lu
avec beaucoup d'attentions le petit
opuscule d'Edward Balladur et lorsqu'il
parle de la reconquête d'une politique
européenne par la France poétique plus
clair plus ferme plus souveraine sur un
certain nombre de sujets c'est la
première question on peut pas parler et
ne pas avoir la maîtrise de ce que l'on
dit Gérald Darmanin n'a pas la maîtrise
du droit il faut que nous la retrouvions
et puis la deuxième chose ça veut dire
qu'on sort des règles de l'Europe ça
veut dire qu'on considère que sur la
question de l'immigration c'est le droit
national ça veut dire que les nations
doivent reprendre la main sur ce sujet
là moi c'est un sujet sur lequel j'ai
changé d'avis parce qu'avec Schengen ça
devait être une question européenne ça
ne marche pas il faut le constater il
faut que la France reprenne la main et
donc en général Darmanin dit qu'il faut
surveiller les frontières extérieures de
l'Union européenne vous vous dites non
il faut se laisser les frontières
françaises qui font en faire ça pour
surveiller les frontières européennes et
il faut avoir un droit que nous
maîtrisons qui nous permet de décider de
qui nous accueillons ou nous accueillons
pas sur notre sol ça veut dire et qu'il
faut être
il faut avoir plus de temps pour décider
ça veut dire que le frein lorsqu'elle
instruit un dossier doit s'assurer que
la personne est à sa disposition et que
si nous ne l'accueillons pas elle est
reconduite à la frontière donc une
politique de soutien à l'OFPRA pour que
le froid décide plus vite
un dispositif juridique qui permet de
reconduire plus facilement à la
frontière oui on a des difficultés avec
les laisser passer consulaires oui il y
aura des obstacles mais la diplomatie
frappa c'est pas la première fois et
puis surtout un choix que le
gouvernement nous dise qui peut rester
en France qui ne peut pas rester en
France il y a un sujet qui ne peut pas
se discuter ce sont les personnes qui
sont réfugiées pour des raisons
politiques qui sont persécutés dans leur
pays parler aujourd'hui de la Syrie on
peut parler de ce qui va se passer et là
au Niger au Mali et au Burkina Faso ou
les mouvements intégrés islamiques sont
en train de recréer un Khalifa ça va
poser des problèmes migratoires énormes
donc ce sujet ne se discute pas la
France doit accueillir et puis il y a le
reste et notamment l'immigration
économique la France ne pourra pas faire
face voyez je suis Lyonnais et
je dis en bulle comme un grand nombre de
lyonnais dans les rues de ma ville et je
vois cette misère qui déferle chez nous
la France ne peut pas les accueillir
donc ça veut dire que parmi les milliers
de gens qui ont débarqué à Lampedusa ces
derniers jours il faut un accueillir
aucun
parce que il y a des raisons qui sont
des raisons parfaitement légitimes de
rejoindre le territoire européen parce
qu'on est persécuté parce qu'on n'est
pas majeur là on a tous les dispositifs
juridiques mais on peut pas accueillir
tout le monde il faut faire des choix il
faut aider l'Italie ou pas il faut aider
l'Italie ou pas vous dites c'est à
l'Italie moi je trouve scandaleux que
l'Europe soit aussi légère sous le
soutien l'Italie c'est un peu facile les
côtes grecques et les côtes italiennes
sont exposés en premier chef et ils sont
européens donc évidemment que nous
devons accompagner les Italiens et puis
évidemment il y a une situation
d'urgence donc il faut répondre à cette
urgence mais c'est pas parce que nous
accueillons les personnes qui sont à
Lampedusa qu'on doit leur donner un
titre de séjour à perpétuité sur le
territoire français
on est face à une crise migratoire une
crise humanitaire également vous venez
de le souligner l'Europe est face à ses
responsabilités vous l'avez évoqué aussi
Georgia Meloni la présidente du Conseil
italien et la présidence de l'UE Ursula
andersayenne ont appelé à la solidarité
des Européens est-ce qu'elles ont tort
d'appeler à cette solidarité dans
l'urgence il faut évidemment que la
solidarité des Européens joue on peut
pas laisser l'Italie dans cette
situation et se fermer les yeux à
l'Italie fait partie intégrante de
l'Europe l'Italie est en premier chef
impacté parce qu'il se passe en Syrie
parce qu'il se passe ce qui se passe en
Libye pardon en Tunisie et dans le
la géographie saharienne et
subsaharienne donc évidemment qu'on doit
accompagner l'Italie si on accompagne
pas l'Italie l'Europe n'a aucun sens de
dire mon voisin se débrouille c'est pas
l'Europe ça l'Europe doit évidemment
accompagner l'Italie mais je le redis
pour une personne que nous accueillons
en France nous devons faire un choix et
nous devons dire qui nous accueillons
qui nous allons intégrer un autre sujet
accueillir oui mais intégré aussi et qui
ne pourront pas accueillir parce que
nous n'en n'avons plus les moyens mais
c'est ce que dit général Darmanin dans
son projet de loi immigration ça fait
partie moi j'attends de le voir moi
si si le texte répond à ce que je viens
de dire un droit européen plus clair un
affichage de principes juridique mais
aussi une politique migratoire mais moi
je le vote en revanche donc pour vous la
question des titres de séjour dans les
métiers en tension ça c'est une ligne
rouge ou c'est pas une ligne rouge
[Musique]
de ma formation politique je pense c'est
un nombre de sujets sur lesquels on peut
ouvrir la porte et discuter non pour moi
et la ligne rouge c'est le droit
européen si on reste à la jurisprudence
européenne et notre texte sera un coût
d'épée dans l'eau parce que vous aurez
un juge d'un tribunal administratif qui
décidera d'une application directe du
droit européen et nous ne pourrons pas
reconduire à la frontière on ne peut pas
rester dans cette situation ou moins de
10% des reconduites à la frontière sont
honorés donc pour répondre très
clairement à votre question moi si sur
ces sujets là j'ai une réponse précise
et surtout crédible crédible parce que
écrire un texte c'est bien l'appliquer
c'est un peu différent donc moi je veux
une réponse crédible sur ces questions
là mais je souhaite pas que mon pays
change de nature c'est une France qui
s'encre dans dans des racines
chrétiennes les grands humains on peut
pas faire les yeux
on va remercier Denis d'avoir été avec
nous les répercussions sur la côte de la
flux de migrants à l'enpédouza c'est à
la Une de Nice Matin faire face à
l'urgence c'est votre titre ce matin
merci beaucoup merci Denis d'avoir été
avec nous on va parler de votre
territoire maintenant ils tiennent donc
vous allez déposer une proposition de
loi pour mettre fin à la métropole de
Lyon à telle qu'elle existe aujourd'hui
on va voir les détails de votre texte
avec Alex poussar qui nous rejoint
[Musique]
bonjour Alex bonjour Yann
blanc avec le député les républicains du
Rhône Alexandre vincentave ont déposé
une proposition de loi pour mettre fin à
la métropole de Lyon en quoi ça consiste
alors pour bien comprendre il faut il
faut remonter avant 2015 quand il n'y
avait pas de métropole de Lyon mais une
communauté
urbaine de Lyon à c’était une
intercommunalité à ses classiques ou
chaque commune était représentée par des
élus
issus des élections municipales à
l'époque cette communauté urbaine de
Lyon avait comme compétences l'urbanisme
la gestion des déchets le développement
économique ou encore l'habitat social et
à partir de 2015 et bien une loi la loi
maptam a remplacé la communauté urbaine
de Lyon par la métropole de Lyon en
créant une collectivité avec un statut
spécial d'abord des conseillers
métropolitains élus par les citoyens
lors d'élections métropolitaine des
conseillers qui ne représentent plus
directement les communes mais 14
circonscriptions géographiques de
l'agglomération lyonnaise et puis cette
métropole de Lyon a gardé les
compétences de la Communauté urbaine
mais a pris des comp supplémentaires
celle du département à savoir la
protection de l'enfance la gestion des
collèges le versement du RSA c'est un
statut unique en France et ce que
prévoit votre proposition de loi Étienne
blanc et bien c'est de revenir à une
communauté urbaine de Lyon avec des élus
représentants chaque commune mais tout
en gardant les compétences du
département qu'est-ce que ça changerait
concrètement et bien l'idée c'est que
chaque commune de l'agglomération
lyonnaise retrouve un pouvoir de
décision dans cette collectivité car
aujourd'hui et bien les conseillers
métropolitains sont beaucoup moins liés
aux communes car il est représentent
d'abord les citoyens qui les ont élus et
puis cela changerait aussi le rapport de
force politique on le rappelle la
métropole de Lyon est dirigée par une
majorité écologiste qui a obtenu plus de
voix aux dernières élections
métropolitaines en 2020 et revenir à une
communauté urbaine et à son mode de
scrutin basé sur les communes serait
plus favorable à la droite lyonnaise qui
dirige beaucoup de petites et moyennes
communes au total pour information 44
communes sur les 59 de la métropole de
Lyon sont dirigés par la droite et le
centre et donc dans une communauté
urbaine et bien la droite actuellement
minoritaire renvoie majoritaire en
nombre de communes pourraient plus
facilement se retrouver au commandes
Étienne blanche une métropole de Lyon
avec des conseillers métropolitains élus
directement clairement par les citoyens
c'était assez démocratique pourquoi ils
mettent fin parce que ça ne marche pas
et en aisant directement les conseillers
métropolitains vous créez une légitimité
issue du suffrage universel et vous avez
une légitimité du maire qui était liée
avec son conseil municipal vous avez
deux légitimités qui sortent un exemple
tout simple la commune de
Saint-Genis-Laval le maire de
Saint-Genis-Laval la mairesse de
Saint-Genis-Laval n'est pas élue au
Conseil métropolitain c'est son opposant
l'as du vélo et qui était très attaché
au développement
des pistes cyclables c'est lui qui était
lu à la métropole et qui s'occupe de la
mobilité mais vous avez un maire
légitime et c'est son opposant qui fait
la politique communale sur la mobilité à
notre exemple tout simple vous êtes
maire la métropole souhaite un
aménagement sur votre vous n'êtes pas
d'accord pour des raisons parce que
proche de vos concitoyens ça marche pas
on ne veut pas de cette aménagement là
la métropole si des di Messi moi je vous
l'impose et la métropole le fait elle
peut se passer de la vie du maire mais
non quoi les citoyens quand il se
plaignent ils vont tirer la sonnette de
leur mère en disant mais vrai écouter ça
va pas du tout ce que vous faites le
maire d'images j'y peux rien c'est pas
moi c'est la métropole donc le maire se
fait tirer les oreilles sur un dossier
avec lequel il n'est pas d'accord et
vous pouvez multiplier les exemples à
l'envie d'opposition de ces deux
légitimités il faut arrêter ça c'est un
vrai semblable et c'est incohérent mais
ça arrive fréquemment qu'il y ait
différentes majorités politiques entre
une commune et la collectivité
supérieure par exemple le département ça
participe finalement du dialogue entre
les élus bien sûr sauf que là vous êtes
sur deux collectivités territoriales qui
sont sensiblement sur les mêmes champs
compétences allez on reprend
l'aménagement de la voirie qu'est-ce
qu'on a de pouvoir policier reste Homère
donc
c'est certain et la deuxième chose et
j'ai été maire très longtemps d'une
commune très proche de la Suisse ensuite
vous gouvernez sur des sujets vous
mettant d'accord avec vos mais il y a un
dialogue il y a une discussion il y a
pas d'impérium aujourd'hui vous êtes le
président de la métropole qui disait
comme ça c'est pas autrement tout le
monde derrière moi et je ne veux pas
voir dépassé une oreille
ça n'est pas démocratique voilà ça n'est
pas démocratique je pense que en matière
de coopération intercommunale c'est le
dialogue c'est l'échange on fait un pas
on accepte on discute et puis finalement
on trouve la voie du bien commun
aujourd'hui c'est pas la voix du bien
commun c'est l'Impérium métropolitain
qui s'impose ce que vous pensez que
votre proposition de loi peut-être
adoptée par le Sénat j'espère très
clairement si dans cet assemblée qui
défend pied à pied les libertés
communales on me dit certaines blancs
tallois elle tient pas la route
cette année plus rien comprendre
[Musique]
dans le groupe elle est régulièrement se
pose la question de l'intercommunalité
l'intercommunalité elle est en train de
se substituer aux communes moi je rêve
d'un texte dans lequel on écrit à
l'article le premier
l'intercommunalité elle est au service
des communes au service des communes je
suis maire j'ai un pouvoir il faut
renforcer la commune et puis sur un
certain nombre de sujets vous constater
que la commune est le seul n'y arrive
pas ou elle est très bien dit les
ordures ménagères l'eau l'assainissement
la clairement les ordures ménagères
quand vous construisez un incinérateur
c'est le périmètre il peut pas être
communal oui on coopère avec ses voisins
on se met d'accord sur un périmètre on
discute d'ailleurs avec la région le
périmètre voilà donc on coopère mais on
ne subit pas un impérium et on se pose
la question aujourd'hui on est mais les
mères ils sont critiqués aujourd'hui ils
sont même violentés ce qui est vrai mais
leur autorité puis l'intercommunalité
toute une série d'autres sujets on ne
cesse de diminuer leur pouvoir et quand
on diminue leur pouvoir on efface le
responsabilité la France aujourd'hui un
véritable problème
identifier les élus qui fait quoi et
savoir qui est responsable d'une
politique mais est-ce que du coup est-ce
que du coup à Lyon comme à Paris ou à
Marseille il faut que le maire soit élu
au suffrage universel direct c'est toute
la question ça c'est un deuxième texte
le système
de la ville de Lyon à côté la loi PLM ça
ne fonctionne plus mais ça c'est un
autre sujet mais ça serait votre sur
lequel je ne suis pas allé je pense
qu'il faut regarder la question quand on
a fait je pense que ça devient une
urgence aujourd'hui faire à Lyon un
maire d'arrondissement c'est l'illusion
du pouvoir il a pas de budget il y a pas
d'impôts il a pas d'autorité il ne
pilote pas les questions de sécurité
police municipale ou autre donc il a
l'illusion du pouvoir mais il est le
titre voilà on est dans une démocratie
on distribue des titres mais on ne donne
pas les responsabilités mais finalement
et à Lyon c'est ça sur PLM mais
finalement Étienne blanc sincèrement
est-ce que votre volonté de redonner du
pouvoir aux communes dans la gestion de
l'agglomération lyonnaise c'est pas
aussi une stratégie pour que la droite
reprenne les commandes par rapport aux
écologistes qui va reprendre les
commandes vous avez ce que la droite
c'est pas ça c'est que quand on me dit
mais c'est une proposition de loi LR
n'est pas vrai moi j'ai présidé une
réunion lundi la semaine dernière
jeudi dernier qui était en face de moi
il y avait des maires centrices et et
c'était la droite
il y avait aussi des centres qui étaient
pas marqués à gauche mais plutôt dans
ses tendances là donc c'est pas une
proposition de l'olr moi ce sujet
politique ne m'intéresse pas la seule
chose qui m'intéresse c'est de
sauvegarder les communes de cette
métropole qui sont en train d'être
écrasés par un pouvoir métropolitain qui
les affaiblit et qui souvent les
méprises merci Alex merci à tout à
l'heure on continuera à parler à
d'immigration et de droits européens ce
serait évidemment à suivre dans le club
on va parler de votre président de
Région Etienne blanc Laurent Wauquiez
dont Erik sottier reparler lors de la
rentrée des républicains comme le
candidat des républicains pour 2027 pour
vous ça doit être lui moi je ne pense
pas que le moment est toujours dit
propice à choisir un candidat à la
présidence de la République c'est très
clairement les Français et je suis pas
sûr que ce soit leur préoccupation
essentielle quand au Républicain et qui
ont fait moins de 5% aux dernières
élections présidentielles qui sont en
train de disparaître du paysage
politique parce que c'est l'élection
présidentielle et qui fait la politique
on va voir la disparition on va voir
comment les choses vont se passer aux
européennes mais c'est vrai qu'il y a
une spirale
c'est qui tout double si les
républicains échouent
[Musique]
sont responsables et puis surtout David
Lisnard et sur un sujet qui m'a toujours
passionné j'ai été député j'ai fait
trois mandats de députés et j'ai
travaillé sur des lois de simplification
c'est le dysfonctionnement de notre
administration et des services de l'État
il faut mettre un terme à cela de
l'hôpital de la justice était il faut
gérer au mieux l'argent public et rendre
la dépense publique efficace pour 2027
David en tout cas il est sur un sujet
que je crois absolument essentiel pour
les enfants donc avant de parler de
personnes et de savoir si c'est Xavier
Bertrand
Laurent Wauquiez ou David lisna je pense
qu'il faut parler du fond quoi c'est ce
qu'attendent les Français merci Étienne
blanc merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invité pendant cette première demi